one of the biggest barriers in making
computers faster is how much power they
consume and in fact one thing that
stopped your computer from having a
faster clock rate where it used to be it
was another gigahertz every year you
double that clock rate is that that
requires a lot of energy and it's so
much that your chips would melt if we
ran them a lot faster and if you look
inside a modern desktop computer you've
probably seen it's got a big tower with
silver veins and fan blowing on it
that's to get all that heat out and
that's making it hard to make the
desktop computers faster in your pocket
you're limited by what the battery can
do and we have had better battery
chemistries over time but again this is
an area where breakthroughs are needed
for cars as well as for devices we have
in our pockets and even for storing
power that's generated from the power
grid we really would love to switch to
renewable power like solar and wind but
the problem is that these only come when
the sun is shining or the wind is
blowing and so you need to store the
power to use at a later time and that's
actually a pretty difficult challenge
batteries are one potential way to do it
pumping water uphill is a way to do it
if you have reservoirs but that itself
presents its own challenge now when you
get down to the battery you've probably
if you've ever looked inside a modern
phone that is if you have one you can
open anymore you've probably seen that
most of that phone is actually the
battery that's the thing which is giving
you all the weight it's the thing that
makes an iPad hard to hold in your hands
because it's got a big heavy battery we
would love to see improvement in that
there are lots of things in the lab but
there's a pretty important rule that
people have come to understand when
someone tells you I can do this in the
lab I can make it for a dollar a
kilogram or whatever it is the price
that they think they can do the correct
answer says okay I'll order a bunch and
then they'll wait I can't actually
deliver them to you so you have to
really make it commercialize before you
can say you have it and that hasn't
happened yet
you